[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and Pat Streets back all
right bad batch season two is now out
and in this video we're gonna be
breaking down the first two episodes
holding out all the Easter eggs in them
and also giving our general thoughts on
how these new entries stack up now in
case you need a quick refresher on
season one the finale dealt with the
fall of topoka city with Hunter being a
captive on kamino rescued by the rest of
the bad batch the group had to team up
with Crosshair once more in order to
escape the doomed City from the sky the
Empire rain fire on the cloning facility
explaining why we haven't seen any more
clones the group managed to make it out
with Crosshair revealing that he'd
actually had his chip removed each sided
with the Empire on his own and the group
then parted ways the series ended with
Nala say being escorted to a mysterious
cloning facility which could be seen by
the patch on the scientist's arm it was
the same one that Dr Pershing wore on
the Mandalorian and it's probably Star
Wars once more trying to explain why
somehow Palpatine returned anyway that
should be fully caught up and don't
forget that good subscribers follow
orders and hit that Thumbs Up Button by
the way a huge thank you for clicking
the video now let's get into the bad
batch season two
now the first episode is called Spoils
of War or as I call it heavy Spoils of
War
now the combat term typically means when
a military force has seized enemy
property and it was coined by the United
States in accordance with the laws of
war this is sort of reflected in the
intro with wrecker and Co racing across
a tropical planet with a container
however it plays into the real Mission
which we'll talk about later in the
video now this title is juxtaposed by
the second entry which is called Runes
of war the two completely opposed states
with one meaning Victory and the other
being the opposite they're chased by
crab people and I've looked through all
the Star Wars data banks but can't quite
find this exact species if you know then
drop it below and there were some that
existed in the cankalo belt but they
look totally different from these
crustacean tortoise hybrids now from
here we jump to Amiga or Omega I'm not
going through all that again that we did
last season but we can see that she's
looking slightly older than she did when
we last saw her her hair's now longer
and she's out of the Camino uniform
showing how she's moved on from that
part of her life here she's looking over
an alpha 3 Nimbus class v-wing which
first appeared in Revenge of the Sith
the show up later in the episode so the
foreshadowing here sets up their
appearance later on carrying a similar
design to the Jedi starfighters these
were actually manufactured by the same
company on the planet kuat Tech has her
studying every ship in the Imperial
Fleet but she looks at the ocean life
and longs to be free like them
Omega is very much this season standing
for Luke Skywalker with him of course
wanting to leave the farm behind instead
of being stuck with his aunt and uncle
Omega even looks like Luke and looks
like Luke and she has a similar style
haircut along with more casual clothes
there are still theories that she's
Force sensitive and we could see her
going on a similar journey to him
throughout this season both she and her
brother Bobo were classified as the
Alpha and Omega and the pair had the
rapid aging removed from them the rest
of the Clones carry they also have
specific skills that have been assigned
to them and it is possible that she was
created a way to try and clone
midichlorians which could lead into the
emperor being brought back somehow we
also see she has a calm link on the belt
around her chest meaning that if she
gets kidnapped like the last season she
has a way to stay in touch the ship
itself has also changed slightly without
now having lots of rust and paint
markings due to it not being serviced as
part of the war effort these colors have
also translated to the bad batches
outfits as well and we can see that they
have a passion for fashion for example
in season 1 wrecker's colors were gray
and red but here we can see that he's
got yellow added into it when Hunter
sits down on the ship you might also
notice that his shoulder pads are green
and white and though these are subtle
differences they actually mean a lot the
empire was all about Conformity and
keeping people in line This is why the
universes were typically white gray and
also black however these bits of color
show how the bad batch is broken free of
their confines and how they're now
carving out their personalities instead
of just being the Mindless clones they
were created to be
Omega out her bow which is now a crack
shot with showing how much he's grown
since we last saw her using it the
rescue attempt works and they return
back to Sid's Paula on odd mantel every
time they went there in season one there
was a weak Wayne and I thorian and it
looks like they've still got nothing
better to do because their back here is
per usual the regulars are in and
they're playing Hollow chess and we can
see that AZ is now working as a
bartender he was one of the only
survivors of tapaka city and I guess
it's nice that they found a purpose for
him we can see some gambling fruit
machines and on the bar you might notice
three pumps if you recognize these
shapes it's because they were in the
most Eisley Cantina in a New Home and
these were also used to make ig88's head
in the back of Sid's bar we can also see
a phase 2 clone Pilot's helmet and here
we meet V whose voice by Wonder Sykes as
she walks around the room we can also
catch a quick Glimpse at a Mandalorian
helmet and also Phase 2 Clone Trooper 1
as well now she's hired them for a job
on the outer rim and this is all taking
place at the home of Count Dooku they
haven't started a hashtag Dooku Revival
lately over at Star Wars and he recently
appeared in Tales of the Jedi located on
Sereno this is the former home of the
Sith Lord and it's weary operated out of
during most of the Clone Wars now this
Blaze first appeared in the Clone Wars
episode Knight sisters when the group
launched an assassination attempt on the
count during the midst of the war they
plan to strike him down when he slept
and we later get this reference when the
characters visit the place and say this
place gives me the creeps this line
could also be a reference to Luke an
Empire who said this on dagobar this
place gives me the creeps the palace has
two large walkways coming off it which
makes it easier to spot Intruders but
since his death is loots anyone's for
the taking and there were lots of
real-life missions like this during
World War II with even the seizure of
Hitler's are being something that was
used as the basis for the movie
Monuments Men now Hunter turns the job
down and we see Omega answering
questions about shuttle classes what
class of shuttle Lambda or Delta Lambda
class very good Lambda class is the same
as what Darth Vader used and it was seen
as a more elegant type of shuttle now it
turns out that there is one in on the
job and SIDS well where that the Empire
will arrive on the planet soon and force
their rule on it like the places that we
saw in season one is very much the idea
that the Empire is ravaging the Galaxy
and that the bats should be doing more I
think it's pretty obvious that they're
going to become a key part in forming
the rebellion and my guess is that
season 2 will culminate with that
happening now in omega's room we also
see a cuddling up to the Tuka doll Lula
which was something that originally
belonged to wrecker she overhears them
saying life is now because of her and
welcome to the wonderful world of being
a parent you ruined me life
now fearing the Empire is shown to be
valid when they come across a destroyed
city that was targeted much in the same
way that topoka said he was just like
how they attacked kamino the Empire
bombarded it from the sky and this very
much led the groundwork for the upcoming
Death Star rather than going in and
getting the hands dirty they prefer to
shoot down on a planet the Death Star
would eventually just blow them up from
space rather than bombarding them with
lasers now as they spy in the location
we can see containers being shipped out
and this is similar to the kyber
crystals being escorted out in Rogue one
they're being carried by class 4
container transports which two were also
manufactured on the planet kuat the
Clones are still being used as well
showing how they haven't really fully
been phased out yet we did see in the
last season how they started slotting in
the Ralph Macquarie designs which was a
nice little Easter egg to show the
transitions now after suspicions arise a
distraction set off and we get the
classic Star Wars Imperial alarm sound
which was contained but two of the
escort ships were destroyed what caused
the blast
after being locked in the container we
see Echo trying to hack a data port and
this is similar how R2D2 does it in The
Saga born to know that the bad batch are
using sunblasts here as well as they are
of course fighting against people that
they once call their brothers that all
kicks off and we watches the batch sneak
through their respective places on the
container the Escape pods are jettisoned
possibly being a nut to A New Hope but
possibly being a rich as well a hunter
and wrecker also Escape using the left
beneath Dooku's desk the team on the
container take the long way down too
after using the containers themselves as
a way to travel back to the planet it's
a big Cliffhanger but you won't have to
wait long to see what happens as we go
directly into episode 2 from here now
the thrusters kick in and they make it
back down whilst Hunter and wrecker flee
into the Rune City Runes of War
and the container itself lands on a
cliff Edge which is of course an old
plot device with something dangling over
an edge it's been seen in things like
the Lost World Italian Job and shout it
to you know the bunch and it adds some
tension to their side of the story now
we learn that the clone troopers are
headed up by Captain Wilco and I don't
think he's appeared before but let me
know below if we've had episodes
featuring The Character because I can't
remember him popping up he sends out his
forces in a low altitude assault
transport which I'm sure you recognize
from first appearing in Attack of the
Clones out in the woods a mega and curl
come across a man named Roman who
symbolically sums up the innocent
bystanders that often get affected by
Wars and man's Quests for power he
doesn't want anything to do with the
loot that's been seized by the Empire
and we discover that Dooku also stole
from his own people in order to fund his
war effort this costs them their culture
and they very much lost their identity
and being classed as separatists again
you got your World War II metaphors here
with countries being seen as carrying
political ideologies even though there
were many citizens that didn't align
with them it's left his home in Ruins
and we catching aat battle tank complete
with a battle droid hanger the top of it
it looks like it was patrolling the
streets with another one showing how the
citizens were often kept in line by the
powers that be using the tank Blaster
wrecker takes down a v-wing and pushes
all of the forces back so that they can
make their escape Tech brings some
culture back to Roman by restoring a
Spotify playlist but during all of this
omega's run back of the container now in
the forest we see some swoop bikes which
carry the same sound effect that the
speeder bikes do
Florida
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ER and we also see them setting up a
heavy repeating Blaster after making it
to the ship we get a dog fight with
wrecker and Hunter as the container goes
over the edge it's here on Mega reveals
that she wanted to get the groups of
normality in their lives but she ends up
letting it go so that they can escape
Roman has to get involved first hand and
he saves the pair after seeing the ugly
side of the war himself he gives her the
kaleidoscope and returns home to
probably probably get murdered anyway
they make it out there and we see
welcome meeting with vice admiral
Rampart who's now learned that the bad
batch is still alive not wanting to lose
face in front of token he ends up
killing Wilco in order to keep his
failing Secret in classic Imperial
fashion he doesn't mind killing his own
men but he now knows that the group are
indeed out there now because of this I
think that he might end up using
Crosshair to take them out and he's
gonna try and do this all under the
radar he of course has the worry that
they're gonna be discovered and then
talking will learn the truth as we know
Rampart isn't in main Trilogy and I
think that this series will have talk
and learning about them being alive this
would make him kill Rampart and then
that would explain why he's not in the
main series though George Lucas probably
didn't think of him and you know what
I'm doing I'm just doing a theory time
dude dude so don't get don't get no idea
media I'm not doing saying it's all
connected
anyway I do think that Rampart will
still want to get the bad batch before
they can make their presence known and I
love the consequences that these two
episodes carry they wanted to get enough
money so that they could live far away
from the Empire but now they've put
themselves in a position where they'll
likely back under the crosshairs okay
either way it was great being back with
a bunch and I had a lot of fun with
these first two episodes they went
overly complicated you know they're not
complete home runs they're not 10 out of
10s but they got me back on board and
slowly eased me back into the bad batch
world I am very interested to see what
happens with Crosshair but like I said
this was just kind of easing us back
into it I did kind of want a bit more
but I'm not mad with what we got and we
sell we still got like 14 episodes left
and you know we'll be back every week
for it so make sure you subscribe and
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
so comment below and let me know we are
running a competition right now and
giving away Dawn of the Dead and black
Academy three subscribers on the 15th of
January and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episodes
we pick the comments out random on the
15th and the winners of the last one are
on screen right now so that you message
me on Twitter at heavy spoilers if you
want something else to watch then check
out one of our breakdowns on screen
right now in which we talk more rubbish
about things that you should like if
you're not then why are you still here
why are you still listening this part of
the video I don't know I'll see you next
time take care peace